hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until dawn now we
got a new thing over here
Jessica appreciate my heroism but he
failed to impress under pressure what
does that mean what am I doing wrong
I'm the flirtiest flirt that ever
flirted oh let me try this again trying
that's one heavy shudder
goddamn those are heavy Gramp there we
go voila Michele D freaked out and it's
hard for me to make keep this up look I
act all super confident and like a total
sexy babe and everything but underneath
I gotta be honest I'm really kind of
insecure no really you've gotta be
kidding you have nothing to be insecure
about you have no idea insecure but you
know it's real
yes I do yeah and that's super [ __ ]
hot oh really
[Music]
mike has such a way with words
oh what a flirt oh the romantic date do
I have to do I have to do motion throws
here Oh
what are they dancing
are they dancing they better be dancing
because those are some weird moves I've
never seen okay okay oh they were taking
off each other oh man
Oh No I'm gonna punch him with all my
muscles
you got it babes I'm on it
Mike's on the job anybody want to get
beaten in a wife-beater
I mean have a guy in a wipe it nevermind
I'm gonna beat you with my fist meet hey
I know the bear got in I probably should
have gotten the gun I'm gonna get the
gun I'm gonna get the gun I'm gonna go
get the gun
darn you I mean I got guns on my arms
but gun better gun better good good
gunning can I gun okay apparently not is
that the dick in the box song
that sounded a lot like dick in a box oh
yeah it's not normal okay it's your
phone
magically came home how is it my phone I
don't know it just came through the
window thank god damn it what those
goddamn [ __ ] probably followed us
out here to [ __ ] with us and just when
we're getting down to business
Hey yes yeah Rex
that means you
[Music]
best thing to shout at the top of your
lungs outside of a cabin door break me
off a piece of that Kit Kat bar I really
wish my last words on that scene weren't
breaking me off a piece of that Kit Kat
bar I don't know if I wish they were
I wish okay well this is interesting
we seem to be in a bit of predicament
Mike ain't go and get nothing oh I'm
playing Ashley that's not Ashley I
believe that's Ashley yeah it's why we
came back up here yeah probably
no it's looped is this the library I
mean my sneaking suspicion is that Josh
isn't everything he's cracked up to be
I see it right now it's staring at me
right in the face
weird weird right I know weird but that
was some sort of like creature monster
that grabbed Jess shouldn't antagonize
him with all that talk of sex it's no
good don't shout about what you're gonna
do especially if it's sex dismissive
it's each other
[Music]
okay think so
look what there was something behind the
box what is that is it a button why
would there be a button that's a good
question should I push it that's my
button is for for I guess you two are
the biggest fools I've ever seen in a
horror movie my person I pushed it we
did a movie right now we are I hope it's
wrong leave it to the Washington's to
have secret passages in their house
super old so should we take a look it's
really amazing because every character
you go gee thanks every character in
this game
well I'm not going ok there we go there
we go ok I just wanted to do a circle
back maybe bear how about you know I'm
thinking about nevermind I'll come back
later
I mean you know just I mean just in case
you know I never see you again I just
want it ok bye ok I'm just gonna go on
my way now maybe there's something over
here hello
why do these pictures look like they're
photoshopped they could have just taken
scenes from the game
holy cow ah honest she can handle it I
don't want to freak you out but look at
this she's a big girl is that I I think
this might be what the spirit board
wanted us to find yeah that's a letter
let me see it
it's sad a threat Chris this is serious
we need to find Josh right now
we sure do let's do that are we good not
gonna get to our rom-com wha man just
why why indistinct to get hot hot and
heavy as it happened with Jess oh good
so are there this is a creepy painting
to have right here let's head straight
into it that's a good decision let's do
all the things that we shouldn't do
right hey I came down this hallway
didn't I hello
you look grumbled are you angry about
something
actually after why would they fail I
guess the family of the owner of this
house so that's not good I guess
it's gonna turn out to be some scooby to
do type mystery going on here
of course locked have no worries nothing
Bad's gonna happen to us inside the
house no phone lines to call anyway what
there was like this wanted poster like
full-on western-style you know so and
Sam really thought there was someone
following her around so so what you're
saying there's some criminal up on the
mountain with us there was a message on
this answering machine I found and it it
was from this sergeant saying that there
was this guy who had just got out of
prison and there was nothing he could do
what do you mean he was saying it like
like a warning I mean maybe that's
whoever was down in the basement before
what under the floorboards in the
library the light well there was that
guy what guy the guy who threatened the
Washington's he said he wanted to take
revenge by burning the whole place down
and I found that crazy psycho letter
Chris if this is your way of trying to
make me feel better you're fired
plant your back foot Chuck no don't
shoulder you're bashing your face
against the door plant with your back
foot kick directly on the door right at
the handle is that Josh oh crap that
ain't good well I think this is bad crap
is that your face oh that ain't good
okay good that's gotta be Josh that has
got to be Josh that's got to be Josh why
why so is this the real game right here
and everything else is like a horror
movie interpretation of what I'm getting
here is this guy Matt you don't know me
well this is an exercise in honesty only
which person from each pair you like the
most
take you time your answers are important
aren't they always
okay who's on the left I prefer sit yeah
I don't trust Josh I do not pro trust
Josh god you're not I prefer Matt yay
the hill yeah
oh no that's Matt of course that's Matt
of course ah Chris is cool but I kinda
like Ashley Chris Ashley Chris I gotta
go with Ashley she's sassy not really
yeah Mike la Jessica little Jessica I'm
not biased I never liked Mike not from
the beginning
don't give me that look Oh God
I guess Emily cuz Josh I like him much
oh god Chrissy of course Josh josh Josh
this is so weird
uh-huh I think I'm beginning to
understand you far better now I'm afraid
once again we rather time don't be too
hard on Joshua yeah and the people who
have been through so much are more
liable to have intense actions so that
this makes more sense is this like the
real game and that's just I thought like
everything about this was so cliched
everyone is an architect one individual
we're considering a boy she has an
interesting history with the Washington
family yes if that is what it is that
would be quite a blessing the land was
sacred to his forefathers s I s sister
ask your whose sister Josh it's it's
gotta be which sister is it then
[Music]
coming here
maybe I know how to handle you - oh here
we go
level insane yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
do you even know that thing's loaded yes
risk storica here we go sure go baby go
I got it
yeah
yes play the game Jessica
[Music]
they did it in a shooter just look at
the thing that's getting her
I'll come on
[Music]
good job
still have your gun where's it good job
[Music]
oh geez owner if every single one of
those can end an impending death
horrible horrible death
Steve Rios
okay boy
yeah monkey boy let's go you may be a
douche and I don't like you but come on
save Jessica funk what a badass oh this
this I gotta do I'm playing now
apparently there was something all right
I got it I'm coming I guess it's no time
to look around I gotta go go go
how about you hurry oh stop looking
around yet douche unsafe keep out I
don't know the meaning of those words
I'm Mike Michael it's the shark I'm not
good with rhymes but I am good with
shooters into the fish worldly crap how
do I even know she went oh
Oh Jessica Oh Jess Jess are you okay get
her off the elevator please off the
elevator off the elevator
[Music]
okay here we go you go down give my dad
today I got you right in the face okay
come on come on hey quick time events
but I'm not gonna fail on this oh okay
[Music]
quick of course quick yes quick so scary
so scary so scary scary scary scary
scary scary scary scary scary
oh god scary okay job done so scary so
scary so scary so scary so scary out
there scary scary scary scary scary
scary scary scary scary I got this scare
scary okay huh oh my heart's found in a
million times a minute
what about Jess shoot him in the leg in
the leg in the leg knee do it's not like
you
[Music]
I already shot economist
okay there we go okay there we go let's
do the thing with the thing yeah there
we go okay all right Oh what don't laugh
at me it's tense okay
[Music]
sorry I haven't like looked at the
camera those Susie was in the window
I've been so hyper-focused I haven't
been able to do anything else
[Music]
Jesus [ __ ] is that place
are you just like are you like not even
worried about Jess not even worried
about Jess anything okay then we're
gonna pretend like everything else never
happened everything is fun burn that
ain't good huh
let me grab that hacky sack Oh ash I
didn't even read that okay okay Lily
ready then yep
this is fun all my friends are probably
dead I don't know why I'm not but I
think josh is at the bottom of all of
this I don't trust that dude I don't
trust him and his porn parties bridal
spared me because I'm a friend didn't
that's a little weird yeah that's bad
it's a whole lot of bad bad stuff
happened
yes yes Lee su lee - I'm alone - Shoni
ash Rooney and cheese a Shamma Lamma
ding dong M night Shyamalan ash lilac
anyone out there named Ashley just so
happen to be named ash of the lead I
think I'll go this way
yeah I'm gonna go this way this is where
the blood going yep this seems bad oh no
no that's real face in there that's a
real face something tells me something's
playing on my deepest fears
okay another totem time methinks that's
a death totem
was that me that was me that might have
been me I think that might have been me
me is in Chris right now it's playing in
my fears what is that a clue there's
some weird [ __ ] going on here
there's some weird cabin in the woods
type [ __ ] going on here is bizarre
bizarre as hell so weird
so weird but so cool so weird and so
cool I want to know how it all
intertwines so weird and so cool okay
ash hello Birds burb burb can I go
through they're gonna go under there
nope it was a fool's errand all along
alrighty then
so Mike's headed up to the sanatorium
Jess probably isn't dead well what ash
yes where am I going
yep I'm pressing x to jason as hard as I
can
oh look another a bad carbon good why
are there so many of these I thought the
family owned this mountain
well best is stumbling blindly free oh
good oh good oh I hear crying this is
probably [ __ ] tonight we're gonna
experiment sort of test for this we'll
need the cooperation of our two test
subjects Joshua and naturally but we're
gonna need one Oh brave participant to
help decide which subject will live in
which will dock
[Music]
please please everyone calm down it's
all very simple Christopher you will
find a lever placed directly in front of
you all you have to do is choose who you
will say
Oh buddy give me a second I can't think
straight just
oh hey on wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait a minute wait a minute oh
god I can't make these decisions you
think about this I need to think about
this I need to think about this for a
long time so I'm gonna end this episode
on one hell of a cliffhanger so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
don't know if this writing of wrong
choice oh god why do I do so I'll find
out in the next episode thank you
everybody so much for watching I'll
sleep on this decision as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]